[Music]
all right welcome back to another
episode of chapelle's world uh i have no
guests today today is a special one
because i wanted to do an episode where
i talk about all the cool things that
i've been doing within recent i just
have a lot of things that i've been
doing in my life
uh up to date that have been super fun
and i want to talk about it and it's
kind of hard to talk about what another
guest because i really want to focus on
the guests and you know all the things
that i want to learn about them so i
wanted to take the time to be a
narcissist
and talk about myself is that what
narcissis is that what it is
yeah is it narcissism yeah
because you know what i get confused
with the two it's like you know you hear
people all the time like people are so
quick to call someone a narcissist and a
sociopath
right yeah that like like it's one of
those terms that are just so loose now
that i'm like
what do you guys even do like
like is everyone a narcissist everyone a
sociopath does everyone have a level of
it it's like ego you know i think
everyone has like a level of an ego
mm-hmm like we all have an ego but it's
just levels to your ego right yeah so
you know and i still don't know what
either of them mean i think narcissist
is just like someone that's
so vain
no not just vanity but like the world
revolves around them like everything's
about them like you ever tell somebody a
story and then their first thing is like
oh that happened to me let me tell you
in my life oh dude those are the people
the most people i can't say the most are
the people that like
this is the thing i hate when people ask
you a question
and then you give a man like they're
like if they're like hey do you do you
like chips
nah i'm not really into chips you know i
really just love chips you know like
they'll do that to segway yeah people
here into like what they want to talk
about like instead of just like hey just
be like hey
i love chips yeah it's like can i tell
you this
they don't really care about what kind
of chips they're like they just want to
get you know they're pringles things yes
they're mine yeah those are the people i
can't stand so i was right when i said
narcissist yeah
look at me just being a narcissistic
sociopath out here talking about myself
talking about what's going on in
chappelle's world chappelle's life
you know a lot of great things have been
going on uh this past weekend
uh shout out to theo's podcast this past
weekend
i was in orange county and i got to um
go see my boys
uh h2o uh shout out to toby morris who's
been on this podcast a couple of times
uh they played in orange county they
opened for uh pennywise they were the
main support is i think is what they
call it in the music world uh we call it
feature act and comedy uh but it's but
it's always a great time
to to see them uh perform
and
toby's uh 19 year old son
max has been drumming
uh for for the for the band and it's
been exciting
to see because this kid
came into a band that's already been a
an established band
already from since the 90s and
you know he's just grown up watching his
father play
and
now he gets to play with them so
um i have a few clips that are just
you know
i mean he's he's insane
i think he got a little bit of
training you know
do your deep dives on this i i don't
know but i think i've got word that he
got a little bit of you know travis
barker helped him out with a few chops
and also uh mackie
uh the drummer for the crow mags
uh also helped him out but play this
clip dude watch him i always film this
specific song it's called ever ready in
this specific part because he kills it
he's just relaxing right now but no
he'll get into it watch
[Music]
you gonna edit out me shaking my head
like that
but look at him
[Music]
is that why drummers are always shredded
i mean yeah they're nice think about
have you ever seen them actually no i
haven't talked about we talk
one of the first episodes we talk about
a fat driver yeah that's like they're
rare yeah they are rare yeah
well he lost a bunch of way there's this
one drummer
who's
insane he was a church drummer his name
is eric moore
i think it's eric moore i think that's
who we talked about is that who we
talked about it was a church he had lost
he was a church drummer they he also
drum for suicidal tendencies
yes and he is absolutely insane but he
lost a bunch of weight but um
it's just dope watching i so whenever i
go see them play
obviously you know i'm vip
i'm with the band i'm walking around
with my with my land you're like hey
what's up like that part in wayne's
world you know talking about when
they're like
that's me so uh and i call myself his
drum tech even though i
i don't drum at all i know i know a
couple beats but i'm his drum tech but
you know the part i will not do you
you've been to concerts where you like
you'll see the band
or
they're like the guitar tech the drum
tech bass tech they'll go out there and
they'll play the instruments for them to
do the sound yeah i don't do that part i
don't want to you know because there's
people watching i don't want to just
go up there you get nervous in front of
people
comedian i just don't want to go there
with my
my one beat yeah because the drum techs
usually the drum techs are good drummers
you know sometimes the drum tech has had
to fill in
right and you know for me
that's
that's not my culture okay
that's not my culture my culture is my
guitar find somebody who looks at you
the way you
[Laughter]
i love it i love watching them play
the thing i'm more fascinated by in
music is drums that's the thing i hear
the most is drums
i just can't play drums i could if i
wanted to well you
max is actually going to give me some
drum lessons so i'll be able to do a
thing
you know it's kind of funny being dude
i'm 35 it's like it's like someone
that's like
it's like an adult that wants to start
taking karate classes
my friend just started doing that like
that's how i feel taking
drum lessons from a 19 year old kid but
he's a good drummer i love watching a
drum this is a solid one too
we're like talking to each other
i'm such i'm such a
what do you call a groupie
[Music]
see
who am i just nodding my head thinking
i'm cool i think i'm so cool right there
very supportive posture listen very
supportive
okay i'm there
i love
i love not only do i love h2o but i just
love
going to shows in general so to watch
shows this way
is like a dream come true i love the ins
and outs of all that stuff
and just
you get to see so much behind the scenes
that you don't normally get to see when
you're in the crowd
and i've done the in the crowd stuff so
many times and i'm like man this is it's
it's a super blessing
and then there's
i think we have a dope picture
yeah look at that
that looks i look i mean little fish eye
a little fish shy i look like a
bodyguard
shout out to that madball shirt i'm
wearing hardcore still lives nyhc but
it's cool you know it's a fun time and
they also let me sing
songs with them don't let me do you know
whatever whatever song i want i usually
do the same song i do
guilty by association uh
it
it's it's
it's a different world going up there
and singing
not that i'm singing i'm more so yelling
but
it's still
you know i just i just feel it i think
it
for me i think it's something that i've
always
wanted and i've always felt and just
never
done
oh you're doing it now yeah i'm doing it
now but like when i think about it i
think that's why i get so hyped with it
and
they all get excited for me whenever i
go there and sing with them because they
know
how much i'm loving it you know i'm like
a kid as a candy etiquette
you gonna edit that out not that i
usually you got it right
yeah i stumbled on the word kid at the
candy store that's what i'm like
go uh go to no no yeah oh yeah you can
go to that picture you can pull that up
dude look at the intensity in my face
shout out to rusty in that mustache
rusty pistachio he's a guitar player and
then that's adam blake the steaming
demon
he's from uh
he's originally from london or whatever
but he's been in their band
i think
the the whole time except for one the
first record but um
[Music]
and i don't i don't know what i'm doing
i just know i'm yelling and
but but people don't realize there's a
look at that jump
i haven't jumped i haven't jumped like
that since cheerleading
that was the last time i jumped like
that where i got oh now i got to send
you
a picture of me jumping to cheer should
we post should we do it yeah while you
do that i'll pull up the instagram hold
up to instagram i got it i mean
this pic this cheer picture is like
solid gold
[Music]
boom
but i'm having fun
it's the energy behind it the crowd's
having fun
you're a natural am i natural what do
you think casey if you were to judge if
you were if you were simon cowell
i think that's his last name if you were
simon cowell from american idol
what are you thinking of that
killed it yeah what killed it you're
like wow i mean yeah you look like you
have experience you genuinely look like
you've done it before and like know what
you're doing i mean i'm doing it stage
presence look at you moving around
[Music]
we're gonna compare these jumps
i cannot wait to oh i found it
all right air drop
to
let me know where you get it
hey yo look at look at the comparison of
the jumps dog
yeah look at that
jump dog lacy is what they call me you
better stop playing
you better stop playing that's some
serious mobility on the left
yeah that's that's what they call a toe
touch
that's a toe touching cheerleading that
was when i uh
that was
my world champion performance that's
when i won world champ world champ
cheerleader lacey
right there baby not as high on the
right it's it's so funny when i think
about when i used to cheer it's the most
i think it's the most random thing
i think i've ever done
like it it doesn't make it listen i do a
lot of things that don't make any sense
okay
but that that one to me
whenever i think about it
i go away
what was i doing
that's cool because i i don't
necessarily think
think about it i kind of was just
existing in it but i was really good at
it
right and you know and actually i went
and visited my old school that i used to
cheer at the one that
they talk about on netflix uh trinity
valley community college the other the
team that navarro competes against
i went visited uh
you know since i was out there in dallas
and i hadn't been there in like 10 years
and it was just
like look at looking at what i do now in
my life that seems like a
completely different
world
than like it just i was there
and i'm like man i used to do this in
like hardcore
but now i'm like a hardcore singer
hardcore comedian
that's what i do now
but i was a hardcore cheerleader
i was so wrapped up in it but needless
to say like it was dope to like c but
anyways just just the comparison of the
jumps
and the uh
singing that i do
what's up we're gonna take a little
break from this episode of me talking
about my life and being a narcissist and
being a sociopath all that stuff and
we're going to talk about one of the
dopest kratoms in the game now happy
hippo happy hippo is a fire kratom for
your brain you can use it before
anything the best time to use it i like
to use it before shows or before doing
uh podcasts all that kind of stuff uh
it's a great focused product it's all
natural so you don't have to worry about
anything crazy going into your body
which is the best thing about happy
hippo so why don't you go ahead visit
happyhippos.com
and use promo code thick boy for 20 off
for life that's porvida
for all my uh my latin folk out there
and use that code as many times as you
want okay so that's happyhippo
herbals.com using promo code dickboy for
20
off
i i'm in such awe
and with the things that i've been able
to do and the things i mean it's it's a
true blessing
you know it's a true blessing to be at
where i'm at because
i don't know i i just never thought i'd
see the day
that i would be doing these things
and it's [ __ ] awesome
it is and like i i don't even have like
a structure of words or like these
intelligent words these clever words to
say to get someone to understand
how dope it is
you know and i just want to keep doing
it i want to keep doing doing it all and
i've been doing a lot with my band
you know we don't i mean we have a name
but
you know what's stuff about a band name
you never sold on it
you know
that's what i think about like the band
corn the [ __ ] were sold on that
they were sold on corn they were like
corn
and i'm like
all right you know get the world debut
of the band name can you share it yet or
not can i share it yet yeah
i mean i'll share it but i just don't
know if we're sold on it you let me know
what you think we're getting opinions
right let me clear my mind getting
opinions
i mean it's so funny i say we're getting
opinions because that's in the name
difference of opinion
huh don't hit
i need something why difference of
opinion like
do you guys not share the same opinion
in the band
it's a good question i think you gotta
look a little deeper i think there's a
reason you're not sold something yeah
there's yeah i'm not i'm not too sold on
it i thought about it because i was like
yeah well the only reason why i said
that it said the only thing reason why
we said yeah is because we have to we
have this we have a show coming up right
and they were like hey we need your guys
band names like sam and send us a name
hey what's your guys band name and
they're like it was an opinion
it's not bad it's not bad you could do
better but you think i could do better
yeah it sounds like it came out of a
reactive place like oh we got super
super name
that's what it is it's the pressure of
trying to make up a band name yeah you
guys got to look inward say what are we
about who are we what do we care about
what kind of band are we
and it'll come to you i mean we'll take
ayahuasca together or something
everybody's going
to take ayahuasca sure
what if we're called difference of
ayahuasca i like that better
that i don't even make any sense
difference of ayahuasca band names don't
have to make sense maybe that maybe
that's also something like difference of
opinion makes a little bit too much
sense it's too it makes too much sense
it's it's a colloquialism
that you hear all the time i don't know
i don't even know what you just said
colloquialism i think that's the word i
think that's right yeah i don't know how
to spell it it's i mean it's tough like
we'll figure it out
here
all right do this
um fans in the comments
leave your ideas of band names but also
you need to look him up because every
time we try to come up with a band name
it's always a bad name already it is
that's it's it is so hard it is tough to
figure out
what to [ __ ] call your band but
anyways so in the comments
or if you want to slide into my dms or
whatever you want to do
give me
banned idea names all right did i say
that right banned idea names yeah give
me ideas of band names do that leave
that in the comments uh either on the
youtube page or you can just slide into
the chapel's world dm
uh dms and uh leave it there what about
difference of a minion
[Laughter]
yo what's up guys we're difference of a
minion
get your [ __ ] hands up now
i want to see everybody moving
let's do it
and then
our whole our whole first album is just
about minions and uh despicable me is
that what it is you know what this
movie's called anyways dude i um
listen
i
a friend showed me this band
i'm about to mention this man a lot of
people know this band already you may
not casey because i don't know if you're
familiar with that world yet a lot of
people know this man a friend of mine
originally showed me them
i want to say in 2015 maybe or 2016
this band called turn style
i don't know if you've heard of them yet
i think you you they were on a playlist
that we did in a in an episode yeah i
think i put them on the playlist with uh
when we had zach zack ass yeah no no
you're spelling it wrong all right well
no no you you almost had it uh s t i
not t y
u and i t y
so this band turn style look at these
dudes they're amazing
uh my friends showed me them in 2015.
and i was getting down with them i was
like okay hell yeah i was like they got
dope vibe to him already appreciated it
and then
they came out with their
the recent record that came out which i
think is called glow on
and this record
i'm gonna say right now it remi it gives
me the vibes of
when never mind like the energy of never
mind you know how big never mind was
this is the vibe this album gives me and
these guys have been having
a massive amount of success and love
from putting out this album
so they're a hardcore band they're
originally from baltimore i want to say
originally from baltimore maryland
they've been in quite a
a lot of them have been in quite a few
different bands before some dope bands
uh like trapped under ice is one of them
that they were all in together which i
love which is a new band that i've been
not a new band but a band that i've
newly gotten into but just by taking the
deep dives on uh turnstile
and then
this other band called angel dust which
is another great band uh shout out to
justice
tripp who's the lead singer of both of
those bands but the angel dust is the
one that he does now anyways back to
turnstile so i started listening to this
record and i was like man this is
an amazing record like it just gives you
all the feels
and i don't know how old these guys are
i want us they might be around
i hope they're around my age
uh
what is it
does it say
go to go to wikipedia
yeah it doesn't pull out
anything
on their ages huh
anyways as i was saying so
once saw this band
i finally got to see them live about two
weeks ago
and
man it was probably
the best concert i think i've been to
to date
i think it's the best concert i will say
it's the best concert
i've been to
today that
put me in all the fields all the vibes
there was something about yeah what made
it the best
what made it the best
you know it was it gave me a feel
that i haven't felt
in a really long time it
i don't want to say it was like it made
me feel young again but it made me have
this feeling
when i would go to shows as a kid every
time i went to a show
it was like this energy of just like
like a
like a freedom alive
like just just so much life
i don't know if that makes any sense but
it just gave me this like big emotion
and i
remember first of all it's dope their
house music that they have before they
come on is all like poppy music like
they had like they were playing like
they were playing whitney houston i want
to dance with somebody meanwhile these
these are this is a hardcore band you
know what i mean this is a hardcore band
so they so they make it a fun vibe and
you just feel it and
and being at that concert i think those
i think they're younger than me because
the the kids in the in the crowd were
they were definitely younger than me i i
know they were younger than me i could
see it in their faces they still got
acne and [ __ ] i was like all right yeah
i was like i'm a little bit older than
this crowd but i'm there with with my
boy toby
and they come out and i just felt it and
i was like whoa i did not expect to feel
this like rush
in me
and like the current comes down and it's
like you just hear the cheering of
people and it was dope because they kind
of were just like standing there
you know
and just
like kind of just soaking in the crowd
like
getting hyped
and then
they go into the first song they go into
the first song
i took my hat off and i said toby hold
this and i went in the pit
i'm 35 years old
i don't go in pits anymore i'm 35. i
ain't trying to go in no goddamn pit i
have no desire to i know people are like
oh you you still got a lot of left in
you in a pig listen
i don't want to do it it's listen it
doesn't feel good the next day it's like
the tough mudder yeah exactly exactly
exactly like the tumble butter okay the
damage that tough mudder did to my body
is what a pit would do to me at 35 years
old so i i you know whatever you know
what i was just like you know what i
reminded me of the way the way i got
into the pit was uh
have you seen white chicks
okay there's this part in the movie
where terry crews
i think he's on molly or whatever
he's like sitting there in a chair and
he's like holding a dog and he's like
kind of dancing and he's like
hold this i gotta go dance and then you
just see him dancing oh that was me
that was me i was like whoo toby hold my
head i gotta i gotta go in there and i'm
sitting here like and it's weird cause
they don't mosh
it's not like a mosh there's some
shoving but it's a bounce
it's dope these kids are like bouncing
they do like a bounce
no it's
because that's how like turnstiles music
is but they do have some like fast songs
where it's like
you know like where you can't get like a
circle pick going stuff like that but
it was just like like i'm like man this
is the best concert i've been to in a
while
you know
and and listen i've seen liam gallagher
live solo
i'm not giving him second best okay i'm
not even gonna tell you where he's at
but i'm saying that is the best concert
i've been to today do you think uh maybe
the newness feeling and
like it was from typically if you're
going to see a band nowadays it's like
you've listened to them for a while and
maybe if you're getting any feelings
it's more of a nostalgic thing whereas
this is it gave me a very nostalgic
feeling but also refreshing
it was nostalgic but also like a modern
feel to it to where it was like yes
yes
i i [ __ ] with this and i was like
and it and it validated my reason as to
being a fan
of these guys
it just it just made me realize even
more like oh yeah i really do [ __ ] with
this band and it's wild because their
their earlier records
aren't necessarily
what
what this current record is that's why i
said it reminds me of nirvana because
nirvana's first record bleach
is completely different than never mind
it's a good record and it's a hard
record
but like never mind just did something
that just
popped
and that's how i feel about
this record like they're they're
i mean they they sold out the novo
theater
two nights which i think is 20
2500 people
i think that's what it fits or whatever
i think it fits 2500 people but the kind
of that like
i didn't know bands did two nights like
that you know
i didn't know that only person i've ever
known to do something like that i guess
i just didn't know
that was the thing in in the music world
but um
what's that guy's name smooth dude sings
all the time
uh
you know what i'm talking about guys why
am i blanking on his name smooth like
hairless no it's not no no like he's a
smooth guy
dances
gosh what is this dude's name he's from
hawaii
i don't even know what to google him
to the moon
what y'all trying to do
24 karat magic and why bruno mars oh my
god oh bruno mars you should've said
little guy he's
he's little oh really yeah he's time i
think he sold out four nights at the
forum
is he even hawaii
i thought he was from hawaii right
nailed it kiddo
he's from hawaii yeah born and raised in
honolulu
honolulu
mars who do los angeles 203 to receive
in 2009 how old is this guy is he my age
uh born 85 so he's my age 36
oh okay so we're two years apart
anyways
um
sold out two nights i bought it listen i
went and bought merch i bought two two
two shirts cause i'm a fan i'm locked in
i'm feeling it and in the the
the type of crowd there was so diverse
it was it was like the dopest feeling
i don't think i've ever gotten this
feeling at like punk shows
like
from back in the day to where it's like
you feel like this is like for everybody
in a sense
because punk is a thing like
during the time when i was growing up it
was like you either listen to punk
and nothing else
like you couldn't branch out any other
way and i think that's what they did
with this record they didn't pigeonhole
themselves into just being that strictly
hardcore band well they'll have their
they'll have like a rise of you know you
know success in the hardcore world but
no they've reached out to the masses
jimmy lovato was at the concert
she said got to see my new favorite band
or my
favorite man she posted a picture with
them
or they posted it
go to demi lovato you know who that is
she can sing her ass off
yeah right there there it is
my favorite band turnstile my favorite
oh hat apparently
yes
but look at that
first of all they're all shredded
they all just look good
dude beat my band we're ugly
that's the band that should be something
about the band name we're ugly it was
ugly
35
35 and ugly 35 trying to start a band
that's the band name 35 and ugly 35 and
ugly
no i actually do feel
listen the reason why i
originally the band started off as just
something that
hey
we're just gonna mess around but then we
actually started writing original songs
i started writing the songs and actually
felt good so i was like you know what
let's let's keep
let's keep doing this you know let's
let's let's do it so i i just been in my
room uh
i've written all the songs so far you
can call me uh
i don't know you can call me uh
daryl hall from holland oates you can
call me that you can call me noel
gallagher from oasis you can call me uh
kanye west you can call me uh who else
wrote a lot of songs
bob dylan you call me bob taylor
you call me dave grohl
you call me ice cube
you call me ice cube
you call me uh yeah you call me i i
would say i'm that you know
that'd be funny it just sucks it's just
bad songs uh i think they're good songs
the people i've played it for
hey and i i tell people hey don't you
don't you kiss my ass on this don't
don't start kissing don't try to kiss my
ass on
i'm like let me know don't let me be a
delusional now's not the time for yes
men
exactly you know i can't just be once
you hit it big in your gajillionaire
yeah and you're touring all over the
world yes then you get some yes man you
just yeah yeah right not right now i
don't need a yes man i need you to be be
honest and i'm not talking about you
[ __ ] online and [ __ ] i'm
talking about my friends
because people online will be like yo
dude uh
someone someone just the other day i had
to throw them to my block party man i
had to take them to my block party
because they were like because they
commented on my video they're like this
[ __ ] sucks and i was like block party
how you gonna tell me that sucks
i don't know you
listen if you're my friend and you said
it sucks it's different but it's like
weird when someone i don't know you and
be more constructive with your feedback
yeah
i'm like let me just give you feedback
on your life [ __ ] i can't
because i don't follow you and i don't
know you
that's the thing that drives me crazy
with that
oh
speaking of kanye west dude did you
watch that doc oh yeah
that was awesome
i cried
wait which part when donda
uh no that got me teary-eyed when he
lost his mom that was i didn't know
that's how that went down
i thought it was like during the surgery
i didn't know she was like it was like
post-surgery she was out of surgery i
thought she was in surgery when she had
passed
um
man that doc got me super emotional
which part just okay so quite a few
parts there was one part when he was
with the choir
the the church choir and they were
singing uh through the wire and he was
like directing him yes that was cool oh
my god yeah that showed you like what
kind of a beast he is just like yeah
because it's starting and they're kind
of scattered and they're not there yet
and the way he whittled it down to
exactly what he wanted like i know they
edit it but yeah seemingly still but it
seemed yes you know probably yeah
probably they were probably in their
that room for a while but
for the sake of people watching at home
he probably had to condense that but
watching that go down
i was
i just started crying because when he
was like what if we did it this way
and then when the when the choir started
singing it it was like obviously the
better version
that he found
and then they like he was like sing it
this way and he did like his little
sound event and then they sang it
and i just started tearing up and i was
like with like smiles
because that was like that was dope that
was the most beautiful thing i think
i've ever witnessed was watching that go
down like that my big take away from it
was like you know people now are like oh
kanye's an egomaniac kanye's this and
that yeah but it's like
you see in the documentary like this is
consistent oh before he hit it he
willed it into existed it's kind of
similar in my opinion um i'm a massive
conor mcgregor fan but connor always had
that same energy oh did he really
i don't know much of his story but same
kind of deal where he's just like
telling people he was going to be double
champion the ufc before he was even in
the ufc yeah it's like well nobody has
been a double champ so it's like it's
kind of hard nobody from ireland has
been yeah all this stuff but like that
confidence that like ego that they both
maintain is like yeah that's a good
thing that's what gets you to this level
yeah i
i just appreciate when people have that
yeah i i don't i'm not opposed to
someone just believing in themselves
that much i'm not especially when they
achieve it yeah especially when they
achieve it it's like why and it's like
why would they stop believing in
themselves when
they get the result that they get
that's how i feel i'm like let them have
that and on top of it the way his mother
believed in him i've never seen anyone
okay maybe this is just personally me
there's probably i'm pretty sure other
people have that in their life with with
their parents or whatever but me me
personally
i can't say that i've had someone
i've ever felt that kind of belief
from anyone in my life okay that level
i think people have always like got like
oh you could do chapelle or whatever but
and the reason why i say it is because i
think i've always pushed that off
and i've put all the beliefs just on me
like i'll do it
and that's just because of the way i
grew up you know what i mean because in
my health like my first household there
was never any like you got this oh
you're doing this that's amazing it was
always like torn down for the things
that i did so i think i just took taken
it and put it on myself
and i've kind of just
you know
other people believing in me or saying
that i could do something
became noise to me so it was just like
noise that i would just push out and i'm
like i got it not not in a disrespectful
way not saying like i don't think it's
nice when people say that it's just i've
never looked for it well it seems like
once you developed it for yourself it's
like
okay thank you but i don't need it i've
already got it yeah on my own yeah i
already got it in me yeah yeah so i'm
not saying i'm kanye west
no but you
i'm chappelle lacy
the lead singer of 35 and yeah the lead
singer 35 and under no no
i love that kind of belief in himself
and there was something that i also
noticed is that he didn't pigeonhole
himself
he went for whatever
he wanted to go for
and also
he the way he trusted
his work
and trusted like what he was doing
like dude one of my favorite parts was
when he was in rockefeller records at
the the headquarters
and he he was like talking to that
secretary he was like hey can i can i
wrap my song i'm working on for you and
he started wrapping a song she gave zero
[ __ ] yeah she's taking calls she gave
zero [ __ ] but you know what i noticed
he never gave up on his performance
yeah he kept he finished it he kept
going that's like a comic that's bombing
and but they but they stay in it
power through yeah you power through it
and it all and it makes you it makes you
better i think everybody should watch
that doc you might find something
out about yourself that you never knew
before because
it made like i was taking notes
there was something he said they said
that i didn't even i've never thought
about this in my life 35 years never
thought about this love is learned in
the home i never really thought about
that until i heard it
it's just like look yeah that's where it
is alert
it is learned at home wow
because we didn't learn that [ __ ] i'll
tell you what
we've literally never said that growing
up
so whenever i was someone i was adopted
they would say and i go what are you
doing
why are you doing that huh why do you
say that word like that dog i was like
you better stop flamer get shoved
tell me you love me darling you know
what
come on get out of here no it's it but
it is it is dope man there's so many
amazing parts but you like you said you
really do get a solid idea
of why he is the way he is
it's it's it's just i mean he's been
that way he's always believed in himself
man
i mean
i don't i don't know like like
it puts you in one of those moves i
don't know if it made you feel
that way but it put me in the mood to
like i want to i want to work hard
not that i haven't been but like oh
there's another level to working hard
that's what i you know i saw that i saw
um
just
i don't know just believing in the
individual self
and and not letting him like everybody
was tearing him the [ __ ] down yeah like
no your producer
yeah his abilities no you're a producer
his ability to block that all out and
also like stand up for himself like
there's that one scene where the guy you
know they're in the hallway and
he's saying this is the best rapper
producer in the game and kanye had to
like stand up for himself in front of
everybody and be like no don't call me
rapper producer i'm a rapper like really
he was just an artist yeah just like a
broad stroke like in
many avenues but so he had to stand up
for himself and be like no don't call me
don't label me yes i'm not that i'm this
i'm gonna be the best rapper period
mm-hmm he i mean he set a tone for like
he he said a set of tone
from the get and that was like before he
was anybody before he was anybody
and the way they just kept hitting him
like yo yo what's up with the beat
what's up with the beat
you know he's like rap too like a rap
dude
when he started uh
rapping for jay-z
the first time he rapped for him
that's a ball that's a like first of all
because obviously especially at that
time
and even still today jay-z is considered
like
one of the top goats
in hip-hop yeah and jay-z put him on
that track and he put him on that track
he's like yo i got you know i got the
bars to this and he just started
spitting and they were feeling it with
them
and then he just went in and he just did
it and then
that's what it is
his hunger has always been the same yeah
his hunger has always been the same yeah
that was like not to be cliche but like
preparation meeting opportunity yeah
that's like that's what success is
uh-huh preparation when preparation
meets opportunity
and
even even uh when they were showing them
clips showing clips of him
working like uh like the later clips
when
he was in like
some i don't know i think
yeah some tropical environment when he
was out so i don't know where it was but
you see him rapping and like
the same hunger he has like today he's
always had you see it in his eyes that's
why i was saying like that's why i kept
telling you know my girlfriend i kept
saying like look at his eyes
look like you can see everything in his
eyes
like you can see
the hunger the like the the the belief
you see everything
what
i don't know i was i was amazed by that
doc i can't get over it did you see i
saw some lil wayne doc a while ago and
he
i mean talk about like
kanye's work ethic the whole documentary
is lil wayne like never not recording
he's just always
like yeah oh that's yeah that's an old
doc i think that came out like
gosh when did that doc come out i know
exactly what you're talking about but
but everywhere he was at he whether he
was in his hotel his tour bus gosh what
was that documentary
[Music]
yes
this
it was carter documentary
yes i saw that doc
yeah that was good the doc is amazing so
common theme like yeah here he is in the
hotel room just like
yep
but but okay and so
that kanye doc started making making me
think about other people
right other other successful people that
are really killing it i've always pretty
much stayed relevant to what they're
doing in their careers
um i looked at cats like dave grohl
i looked at cats like kevin hart
um
yeah i'll use kevin hart next example
you see the same hunger i've seen his
earlier stuff
you see the same hunger it it's like
they have this ability to not let
anything get to them
in in
intern anyways things okay that's what
i'm trying to say now i know what i'm
trying to say i got this
i dropped out so what i'm trying to say
is they have this ability to take
anything that's thrown their way that's
a negative thing
not and not necessarily overlook it is
just take it and make it positive
it's like they take these
negative things grab them and go okay
thank you thank you thank you thank you
and then boom yeah how can i use this
how can i use this that's what that's
what i see in a lot of those people
because when you think about dave gross
story
like he said after after nirvana
people were like what how could you how
could you do a
a rock band or whatever
you know how could you how could you do
that
and then he was like what do you want me
to do reggae
like like
this this is what i do i make rock music
like
what did you want me to just stop doing
the thing that
i've the only thing i know
it's [ __ ] amazing
i don't know
i think i think i'm uh
i don't know it just put another level
of work ethic in me
that i'm excited to
use and
catapult off of i was journal journaling
about the doc
i was taking notes while the doc was
going on
and
you know what's crazy i know i don't i
don't talk much on pop culture and [ __ ]
like that
like this [ __ ] with like kim
mm-hmm uh him and kim kardashian
like watching that guy go oh that makes
sense
from her perspective no like from him
like why he
like why he's trying so hard
to be back with her being her life or
whatever
i mean from what i've noticed
it makes sense because
yeah that's what he does he works hard
for the things he wants oh i see what
you're saying did that make sense yeah
yeah yeah that's how i saw that i was
like oh that makes sense yeah
i was like now that whole thing makes
sense and then pete david said his head
negative thing to him people i'm like
he's just the guy that just happened
listen i think any guy that has to
follow kanye
and starts dating kim kardashian oh
you're gonna be dealing with some [ __ ]
you're gonna be going through it
everybody gonna be looking at you like
who the [ __ ] are you
it's so funny how people get in people's
relationships like that
i'm like eat a dick leave people alone
it's not your relationship it never was
your relationship
gosh
anyways i think casey's got some rapid
fire questions yeah you're in the hot
seat now i'm in the hospital yeah
rapid fire questions favorite musician
interaction since you've been doing a
lot of uh hanging bumping elbows with
musicians and going to shows and stuff
like that so what's your favorite
interaction with musicians
favorite interaction uh interaction with
a musician
oh i'd probably say uh with henry
rawlins this this specific photo right
here actually
it was that yeah this this this was in
columbus
ohio
and
i was performing in the comedy
tent
with uh
with henry they had a comedy tent and i
was doing the show at this big festival
and
me and henry rollins trailers were
connected to each other now henry
rollins to me
is like my
my lord and savior my lord and savior
henry rollins i don't know why i did
that voice what
it was churchill you gonna edit that out
i wish i could i
just don't know how the truth is i'll be
honest i'm gonna come clean i don't know
how to edit
i'll just all this time all this time
she's like i just i just hit this button
that button and hey that's all i got
all right favorite favorite live concert
favorite live concert
um i
favor like concert
oh i said it turn style oh yeah
but i'll give you a favorite live
concert moment hit me it was 2004 i want
to say i was 16 years old
or 17 or 2003 i went to go see
um
circle jerks and gbh
at uh the marquis theater and i remember
i did uh cheer practice to go see this
show because i was like oh two of my
favorite bands
playing playing together had to go see
it so i go see
um the show as a kid i walked all the
way to that [ __ ] venue and when i
think about it now i'm like that was a
far [ __ ] walk but uh
cool moment so the the lead singer of
circle jerks keith morris was the
original singer for black flag
and
the tattoo i have on my stomach nervous
breakdown
was the song that he sang the first that
he was the first person to sing that
song
and circle jerks had closed with that
song
and the [ __ ] the show had barricades it
was it was a dope venue it was kind of
like the novo theater or whatever i
don't know if you've been over that way
but um
he was like come up if you want to sing
it like just to the crowd
and then did that main guitar riff
started going and i was like oh
i
gotta i gotta dance
hold my dog hold my dog yeah
so i jump over the barricade right to go
sing this song and i get tackled i get
tackled by this bouncer and we break
something i don't know if it was a
speaker or would like some type of wood
wooden thing we break and he's holding
me down big dude and i was
16 and i wasn't i wasn't the size that i
am now you know
i was a lot slimmer but
i get tackled he told me down and i'm
like i can't get up and all of a sudden
i see his head like bobbing like that
right and i'm like what the hell's going
on and i just hear get the [ __ ] off him
get off him i get off this kid and then
the he rips the bouncer off and the hand
sticks out and it was the lead singer of
circle jerks keith morris so he pulls me
up
i hop on stage
right
and it was like the last like 30 seconds
of the song
and he's singing it and i'm singing over
his shoulder right and then he looks at
me
and he gives me the mic and he lets me
finish
and i finish the song and then
of course i did a backflip at the end
yes
damn that's dope yeah it was kind of
crazy so that was the first time i ever
like
been on stage like that that that's
still hands down my favorite
concert moment that's awesome
and then everybody knows you're a
band t-shirt aficionado
so what's your favorite band t-shirt
gosh my favorite band t-shirt
i could do one for right now
give us past present i'm trying to think
of one i always wear oh you know what
i'll you my favorite band t-shirt right
now is probably
the recent turnstile one i bought i
purchased it says uh thank you for
letting me see myself on the front and
then on the bag it says thank you for
letting me be myself they have such a
positive message and it's so dope and it
just
i don't know it just brings everybody to
the [ __ ]
like hey this is eight we're here to be
positive we're here to be cool we're
here to take care of each other let's
have fun that yes that's me
that's what i'm trying to do
so if you don't [ __ ] feel that with
me
[Laughter]
you're not trying to be too positive
you're not trying to be positive with me
then you can eat a dick
all right now it's that time chappelle's
playlist this is just a solo playlist
does it just this is the solo playlist
rylan off yeah i'm rolling off okay uh
what are we talking about so i'll do it
i'll do a turnstile song
i'll do
a holiday
i'll do a trapped under eye song since i
talked about them
and i'll do the song backstabbed
and then i'll do uh
i'll do an angel dust song since i
talked about them as well
and i'll do uh
rec uh no no i did that last time i'll
do toxic boombox
right
uh i'll do an h2o song
i'll do
[Music]
i'll do spirit of 84
right
and then i'll do a kanye song
kanye west since we talked about him
i'll do
yeah through the wire yeah we'll do
through the wire such a [ __ ] gosh
that made that song even more beautiful
seeing how it was made uh
i talked about ice cube
uh i'll do ice cubes summer vacation i
think i've done that one already but
okay who cares
uh let's see what else
um
we'll do demi lovato
we'll do uh since i talked about her
what's that song uh give my heart a
break gonna get my heart we'll just put
that in i'll know what to
how many we got
um
since pharrell was in the kanye dog
we'll do a pharrell song
i'll do pharrell angel
fun song i talked about jay-z we could
do jay-z
uh let's do jay-z
you don't know
uh how many we got
one more one more
okay
uh who else did i talk about
we'll close it out with uh my favorite
content moment we'll talk about circle
jerks we'll do circle jerks
and let's do
behind the door
boom
all right
thank you guys for tuning in i love
doing these solo episodes i'll do some
more just a collection of all my
thoughts and all my gatherings of all
the dope moments
um
you know of course yeah we'll still have
guests and stuff but i like
you know
switching that up and being able to talk
about the things that i want to talk
about the things that i've been doing
and just want to share all the dope [ __ ]
with you guys as you
follow me on my uh
whatever whatever you want to call it
journey journey of life uh so this
weekend march 10th through the 12th i'll
be in freaking springfield missouri
which i heard is like yo
they're like they're like you got vegas
you got atlantic city you got miami and
you got springfield missouri that's what
i heard i've heard that and i better and
i better get that when i get there okay
uh then april 9th
uh sorry april 8th and april 9th i'll be
in salt lake city at wise guys comedy
club and then
just announce new club in san diego uh
may 6th through may 7th mike drop comedy
club in san diego
uh then
the last one i can't read oh uh may 12th
i'll be i'll be doing a one-nighter in
the hometown at stand-up live comedy
club tickets at
chapellelacy.com thank you guys for all
the love thank you for listening to my
episodes and uh just yeah keep on tuning
in